So here I've written the utility function.
I called this utility function "The Winning Differential."
And given a state,
it tells me what that differential is--
expected differential for that state.
And what it says is if we're at the end of the game,
if somebody's won,
then before, remember that our utility function was 0 or 1,
but here utility function is my score--
which is me, and I'm going to reap the pending--
minus your score.
Otherwise, we just do the same thing with a Q function
that we did before.
And note that we're always careful to memoize these functions,
because they're recursive, they're recalling themselves over and over again.
We don't want to repeat those computations,
so we memoize them so we only have to each date computation once.
Now, what I want you to do is write the strategy function.
This was the utility function over states, now I want you to write the strategy function.
You can do it in terms of what we've defined before